what's up guys today's earth day and
everyone's talking about climate change
one of the key things around the climate
change debate that i think needs to get
more attention is the role that bitcoin
mining can play what do i mean all the
critics they keep yelling and screaming
saying bitcoin is using too much energy
but actually when you go when you do a
deep dive you go you study exactly how
bitcoin mining works what you realize is
that bitcoin mining has two key
components to it that end up having it
be a positive for climate change efforts
the first is that it can actually
stabilize electrical grids even though
people are moving to renewables things
like wind and solar ultimately what
happens is that mother nature turns off
those sources of power so that leads to
grid sometimes having surpluses and
other times having deficits when you
introduce something like bitcoin mining
what the grid is able to do is in those
surplus moments they can offload that
power and use it to mine bitcoin and
then all of a sudden when they have
those deficits they can take the power
that's been diverted and bring it back
onto the grid stabilization of the grid
means that renewable energy actually
becomes much more viable for very large
energy consumption geographies and so
ultimately bitcoin mining stabilizing
grids leads to more renewable energy
which is good for the environment the
second thing is that bitcoin miners have
raced around the world to do gas flare
capture ultimately when you are looking
for oil and you're drilling a lot of
that gas ends up getting flared off
super destructive to the environment
it's one of the worst things that we as
humans do to the earth but now bitcoin
miners they go right to the wellhead and
right at that point that that gas is
being flared they capture it they turn
it into true energy and electricity and
then they mine bitcoin with it the fact
that they can do this anywhere means
that there's no cost to actually moving
that energy somewhere else and so you
drop the cost of doing the gas flare
capture and then you turn your waste
stream into a revenue stream gas flare
capture as a way to go ahead and power
bitcoin mining has become a massive
massive business we know that konoko
phillips exxon and many others who
aren't publicly talking about these
large energy producers they're all doing
it and my guess is that this is going to
become one of their most popular use
cases for that gas flare now whether
we're talking about stabilizing grids or
gas flare capture what we know is that
bitcoin mining is driving r and d in the
renewable energy space we know that
bitcoin mining is having a positive
impact on climate change efforts and
ultimately bitcoin miners regardless of
what the critics say is going to be one
of the key solutions it's still in the
early days and there's a lot of work to
do we still have a lot of research and
also just hard work that we got to go
build infrastructure and get this stuff
working but the promise of bitcoin
mining and its positive impact on the
climate change situation is quite
encouraging i hope that you go learn
more about it if you're under earth day
if you're into climate change mitigation
you should be into bitcoin mining i
think if you do the work you'll come
away very happy hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time